finishing the cool down when this big
hulking man walks on the big guy looks
me right in the eye and he uh he gives
me one of these he goes uh
oh you you got any gum
you got any gum
he asked you for some gum
that's right
he's not on the show
are you any gum
so they went to jay big jaw leno and
they said uh jay uh we're we're taking
your show away from you yes and uh jason
yeah okay that's pretty good
yeah i was gonna suggest that right
it's amazing that the underdog won yeah
well let me tell you something every dog
has his day but it's night time no time
for dogs dogs are asleep so it's cat
time cats come out at night freaks come
out at night
shackle-free
i was in fence bam
can't talk about nothing man
somebody walked up and said there's dave
chappelle i thought bam wu-tang
i love dave because he always used a
very intelligent word to go with his
hood i was beside myself
i was chartreuse
hi am christopher walken
he never heard me
i never heard before
i just assumed everyone could everyone
does it so i tried can't keep a good man
down can you brush
kenya
you look at me when i'm talking to you
son
hi shaq how are you i'm good
um i see you doing a lot of commercials
these days you know i've played a long
time in basketball it's one of the most
diverse senses
but i have a lot of fun doing the
commercials obviously
you're like oh y'all know all my
commercials but i've always been a
renaissance man they were like you know
do you want to perform
at a comedy club and i was like nah nah
nah nah
and uh
and then they're like you know we've
seen some beautiful theaters here
in austin do you want to perform at
theater and i was like nah nah i've
dumped that and i've done that before
and uh they're like well where would you
like to perform and i was like ideally
a costco if you could
if you could empty a costco
i would love to do that that would be no
costco what about an airplane hangar do
you have an airplane hanger
somewhere you store helicopters in
he should the
one show we just come out and just talk
crazy now
i would like to talk to
some of the people
who feel
that i should give back my
trophies
[Applause]
just because
you may have heard recently
that i allegedly put the pill into
people's chocolate
i wish somebody would come up to my
house talking about give up the trophy
because you put the pier to the people
chocolate you get stuff
cause i'm not giving back
and and whoo
is
hannibal barris
[Applause]
has
[Laughter]
uh john mccain is the uh new president
uh ladies and gentlemen and uh he says
that life is a pow had no effect on it
but rumor has it he just installed a
water board outside the white house pool
guess i won't be going
swimming over there will i
alright so uh
john mccain i had his arms repeatedly
broken
during captivity and to this day he
can't raise his arms above his shoulders
i guess that explains
dude
hey uh hey what are you looking at but
ed hey why don't you make like a tree
and get out of here
you know that that that is a great line
that is so great
the stuff you guys are doing with the
50s and everything huh no i had jackets
like this can you believe me i'm the old
guy take my wife please take her
no
no
i'm only bullied
i i i love my wife
but she don't know how to cook
her cooking is so bad
it's terrible
[Music]
[Music]
but
[Music]
i say
[Music]
[Music]
good night everybody
muhammad
how do you feel about boxing today has
it changed since your reign
it's been a long time since i've done
this
people use the things your favorite is
going with me i can't wait to show
everybody i'm coming back and sell the
old sales over say i couldn't do it no
more
fight mike tyson and sure but i'm still
great and beat everybody in the morning
doing my face still pretty
oh no it's real simple dave
that's real simple
all i got to do is
let go of the illusion that i exist
drive around on my lincoln
roll in this booger
do you like sandwiches that have a
toothpick in them
okay with green and red cellophane
i do too
perhaps we should begin a club i don't
know
well you know the thing is is that you
know it's it's game sex and you know
it's gonna be tough you know it's gonna
be tough they just gotta you know
they're gonna buckle down we gotta get
out there i'm gonna go take some losses
and get ready for the game you know but
i mean at the end of the day you know
you just you just have to you have to
play you got to play if you don't play
then you don't win if you don't win then
we don't have anything
i can't believe i ate the whole thing
because tracy told me that you he went
to your house and you made him
as he said over and over again to me
bullpark franks
he said i went over there he made me
pranks more pop franks
that's why i'ma always be cool with
eddie because he may be them frank
and when i was young they used to call
me fat murphy
that's when he told me that see now what
separates me okay from like hollywood
directors okay is that that i have a
like i have a huge head all right okay
now i don't mean i have to be ego okay
because i don't all right i mean my
actual head is huge all right i mean i
have to sleep sitting up okay like the
elephant man or i'll die all right but
but okay get this though okay it was my
huge head okay that thought up
who was perfect to play marcellus's wife
all right my name is dwayne the rock
johnson
uh
known as the champ um
here doing
here doing some interviews
uh and i'll be interviewing
kevin hart
order a lemonade for me
little child
and if you don't order a lemonade for me
you're gonna go right to hell